[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau de l'année
d'interdire la réforme de
l'assurance-chômage voulue par le
gouvernement doit entrer en vigueur en
juillet prochain
les syndicats cgt fo et cfdt ont
l'intention de s'y opposer en déposant
un référé suspension devant le conseil
d'état
selon l'unedic l'association qui gère
l'assurance chômage en france en
coopération avec pôle emploi
cette réforme touchera beaucoup plus de
demandeurs d'emploi que ce que dit le
gouvernement et les baisses des
allocations pourront être conséquente
et puis il est reproché à l'état de
vouloir reprendre en main le régime
d'assurance chômage
en imposant à l'unedic des objectifs
d'économies allant bien au delà du
retour à l'équilibré du système
alors pour en débattre nous avons invité
ain et doubs qui était que de myst
maîtresse de conférences au cnam
chercheuse au s'est tu et le centre
d'études de l'emploi et du travail ainsi
qu'au laboratoire interdisciplinaire de
sociologie économique membre du
collectif des économistes atterrés vous
vous opposez fortement à la réforme de
l'assurance chômage est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire pourquoi en quelques
mots absolument alors d'abord parce que
la crise sanitaire a appauvri les les
plus précaires il ya eu une augmentation
de la pauvreté alors elle est pas mesuré
officiellement mais on a beaucoup d'
alerte des associations et le
gouvernement prend la décision de passer
une réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
va pénaliser 40 % des allocataires une
proportion très élevée d'une manière
tout à fait sans précédent
et donc voilà alors que la reprise n'est
pas du tout là donc on est encore dans
la crise sanitaire on n'est pas tout à
fait sûrs d'en sortir cet été
et donc voilà c'est une réforme tout à
fait quand on se trouve et chic rock
morel vous vous êtes ancien inspecteur
du travail devenu avocat
vous êtes un expert en droit du travail
reconnu depuis 20 ans vous avez été
conseillé de quatre ministres du travail
entre 2007 et 2012 et conseiller social
d'edouard philippe lorsqu'il était
premier ministre
êtes l'auteur d'un autre droit du
travail est possible coécrit avec
bertrand martinot et de durée et
aménagement du temps de travail
j'ajouterai pour
finir que vous êtes senior fellow de
l'institut montaigne dans le domaine du
travail de l'emploi et du dialogue
social
vous vous êtes favorable à cette réforme
de l'assurance chômage ce que vous
pouvez nous dire pourquoi parce que je
pense qu'il est nécessaire de se doter
de tous les instruments qui vont
permettre d'accompagner le plus
efficacement possible la reprise qui va
suivre
à compter de la fin de cette crise
sanitaire que nous vivons maintenant
depuis plusieurs mois cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage
elle a été mise de côté pendant un
certain temps mais elle est nécessaire
avant la crise et elle le sera tout
autant en sortie de crise
en plus elle a été conçue et adaptée
d'une telle manière qu'elle va monter en
puissance progressivement et donc elle
accompagnera de la manière la plus
efficiente possible sept reprises pour
des emplois précisément durable et de
qualité
alors justement c'est la première qui
est sûr je voulais pour vous poser
pourquoi faut-il réformer l'assurance
chômage alors la parole est à vous
franck morel puisque vous vous l'estimé
nécessaire pourquoi est ce qu'on a
besoin de réformer cette assurance
chômage
on a besoin de réformer l'assurance
chômage parce que dans une politique de
l'emploi dans une politique qui veut
faire en sorte que le marché du travail
soit le plus inclusif possible
on doit utiliser tous les leviers qui
sont à notre disposition
alors il existe bien évidemment des
leviers qui consiste à activer un
certain nombre de mécanismes des dalles
embauche d'accompagnement je dirais des
demandeurs d'emploi pour leur permettre
d'accéder à l'emploi mais il existe
aussi les leviers au système
d'indemnisation aux critères
d'indemnisation du chômage
c'est le biais là ils sont multiples ils
sont parfois extrêmement compliqué mais
ce sont des leviers qui peuvent être
extrêmement puissant pour inciter les
différents acteurs qui sont des acteurs
qui font des choix économique rationnel
dans leur manière de préparer d'activer
leur recherche d'emploi dans le type
d'emploi qu'ils peuvent être amenés à
rechercher et bien ces leviers de les
adapter le mieux possible pour permettre
de répondre aux besoins du marché du
travail
alors il y en a plusieurs et moi je dois
déjà pointé en premier lieu un point qui
est extrêmement important c'est que nous
disposons en france d'un système
d'assurance chômage qui est un des
systèmes les plus généreux d'europe il
faut le dire et qui restera même après
la réforme l'un des systèmes les plus
généreux d'europe on a plusieurs
critères qui en attestent
qui ont été démontrés par un certain
nombre de deux je dirais de mesures qui
permettent de se comparer au royaume uni
à l'allemagne et la belgique à la suède
à tout un pays de tradition extrêmement
différentes et donc on restera avec un
système qui restera l'un des plus
généreux d'europe ça c'est un premier
point
et puis le second point c'est que tous
les leviers qui sont activés à savoir la
question des différents paliers
d'indemnisation leçon en étant adapté
par exemple la question de la
dégressivité n'a pas été abordé de la
même manière pour l'ensemble des
salariés
elle a été nourrie des je dirais des
expériences précédentes qui ont pu
exister sur la dégressivité puisqu'on a
eu une dégressivité qui a existé entre
1992 et 2001 et qui ont permis d'en
tirer un certain nombre d'enseignements
donc la dégressivité a été adapté pour
être la plus efficace possible
et puis le noyau de la réforme c'est le
mode de calcul du salaire journalier de
référence
il y avait quand même un point dans
notre mécanisme d'assurance chômage et
seacom qui était totalement inadapté
c'est que on ne favorisait pas la
reprise d'emploi durable et on avait un
système qui structurellement favoriser
l'emploi morcelé par cdd repris de
reprise de travail successives
vous savez que avant la crise sanitaire
on constatait que à peu près huit
embauches sur 10 étaient des embauches
en cdd que la plupart de ces embauches
et cdd était sur des embauches sur des
emplois de courte durée et que surtout 7
sur 10 de ces embauches et adhérer
embauches c'est à dire avec le même
employeur est donc l'un des objectifs de
la réforme c'est précisément de faire en
sorte qu'on accède plus favorablement à
d emploi de longue durée à des emplois
en cdi ou à des cdd de plus longue durée
est l'un des leviers qui est utilisé à
cette fin c'est le mode de calcul
l'exemple que je peux vous prendre c'est
celui de deux travailleurs de deux
personnes l'une qui travaille à mi-temps
en cdi et l'autre qui travaille un jour
sur deux à temps plein sur des emplois
en cdd pour une même quantité de travail
sur la même période
et bien malheureusement le système tel
qu'il était organisée aboutissait à
pénaliser la personne qui était en cdi
au profit de la personne qui était
employé en période de cdd entrecoupées
de périodes de reprise de travail ça ne
sera plus le cas avec les nouvelles
règles de calcul
alors on se souvient c'est muriel
pénicaud à qui avait cité cet exemple là
en disant qu'on pouvait très bien vivre
en france en étant au chômage un jour
sur deux ce serait donc une des raisons
d'une des nécessité de réformer le
système à des doux alors bye beaucoup de
choses hein je dirais que d'abord cette
réforme alors auto sur des hypothèses
fallacieuse l'hypothèse selon laquelle
les précaires choisirait de travailler
un jour sur deux parce que ce serait
plus intéressant de travailler à mi
temps comme si les demandeurs d'emploi
avait un menu dans lequel il pourrait
choisir entre travailler à mi-temps ont
travaillé un jour sur deux donc voilà
déjà à ça c'est la première aberration
et c'est ça participe d'une tendance à
la stigmatisation des demandeurs
d'emploi quand on observe déjà depuis
des années à tous gouvernements
confondus on doit dire d'ailleurs
je dirais que la historiquement ça peut
s'expliquer par le fait que depuis la
fin des années 70 c'est la montée du
chômage
tous les gouvernements donc échoué dans
les politiques de l'emploi c'est-à-dire
dans les politiques de création
d'emplois on a assisté depuis à une
montée du chômage graduelle et
finalement avec des solutions qui sont
toujours parfaitement inefficace et donc
il apparaît plus pratique de de
considérer que c'est des demandeurs
d'emploi qui sont rationnels et qui font
le choix de patrons travailler ou de
choisir d'être à mi temps ou en cdd
alors si on reprend un peu histoire de
l'assurance-chômage vous dites que
l'assurance chômage en france est l'une
des plus généreuses d'europe je pense
que on va pas faire des concours de
critères 1 iliad
assurance chômage qui sont plus
généreuses que l'assurance chômage ac en
france mais ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
historiquement un peu partout en europe
d'ailleurs les droits des demandeurs
d'emploi se sont érodés au fil du temps
et d'ailleurs à mesure que le chômage
augmentait et on peut dire la même chose
des droits des demandeurs d'emploi en
france depuis les années 80 les droits à
l'assurance chômage les plus précaires
se sont considérablement amenuisées les
jeunes sont pratiquement exclus de
l'assurance chômage
les femmes en 92 qui a une réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui a énormément
réduit les droits des demandeurs
d'emploi qui sont à temps partiel et
donc si effectivement mais mieux
indemnisés au chômage quand on est en
cdd pour contourner à temps partiel
c'est bien parce qu'il ya déjà eu une
réforme qui a érodé les droits des
demandeurs d'emplois à temps partiel et
notamment des femmes est donc là je
dirais l'étape supplémentaire de cette
réforme c'est de de constater que
finalement on est mieux indemnisés en
cdd qu'à temps partiel et donc au lieu
de se dire que finalement le temps
partiel peut être qu'on pourrait
indemniser un peu mieux parce qu'il est
très souvent subi il s'attend pas une
beaucoup de pauvreté laborieuse et bien
non ont choisi de couper dans les
allocations chômage des demandeurs
d'emploi en cdd
et donc voilà ça ça participe du
raisonnement et bien sûr ce choix il a
été fait à un moment où le gouvernement
avait décidé de
d'ailleurs en passant sa commune mesure
de progrès et d'amélioration du pouvoir
déchu d'achat des salariés en baissant
les cotisations sociales pour financer
l'assurance chômage et en reprenant la
main sur l'assurance chômage
donc l'état à imposer des objectifs
impossibles aux négociateurs de
l'assurance chômage des objectifs
d'économies
c'est ça qui a présidé à la réforme de
2010 9 et je dirais la crise sanitaire a
mis un petit sursis dans cette réforme
puisque ovine
il apparaissait impossible de durcir à
ce point les conditions d'indemnisation
pendant la crise elle est d'ailleurs
l'unedic alors que son déficit était
considéré comme étant tout à fait
insoutenable
l'unedic a été mis à contribution dans
le financement massif du chômage partiel
qui a permis de soutenir les emplois et
aujourd'hui on revient vers un programme
d'austérité et donc on impose de
nouveaux cette réforme qui avait été
belge dire est invalidée par le conseil
d'état et qui va appauvrir
considérablement les demandeurs d'emploi
alors que je rappelle quand même hein il
ya un peu moins d'un demandeur d'emploi
sur deux qui est indemnisé à l'heure
actuelle donc là il y en aura encore
moins et le taux de pauvreté des
demandeurs d'emploi avant la crise
sanitaire et des était déjà de plus d'un
tiers donc bien sûr on comprend pourquoi
il ya des récits des réticences des
partenaires sociaux à cette réforme
parce qu'effectivement dans un contexte
qui est encore très difficile
on n'est pas du tout sortis de la crise
sanitaire
la reprise ne s'amorce pains on est dans
une aujourd'hui dans une activité
économique en dents de scie on peut
prévoir que des emplois vont continuer à
être détruits et malgré ça on fait
passer en force je dirais cette réforme
de l'assurance chômage
donc il sait pourtant que l aura des
conséquences sociales tout à fait
désastreuse
franck morel je devais faire un point
justement sur sur l'idée qu' on a loué
le l'assurance chômage la plus généreuse
une des plus généreux d'europe l'une des
plus généreuses
on l'avait en dans les années 70 c'était
la plus généreuse
je me souviens d'avoir posé la question
alors ça président de la république
valéry giscard d'estaing pourquoi
aviez-vous et est si généreux
quand vous étiez président et il m'a dit
oui tout simplement parce qu'on pensait
que le chômage était conjoncturelle elle
était liée à la crise du pétrole et que
si on avait su qu'il était structurelles
on aurait sans doute été moins généreux
d'ailleurs par la suite mme avait-il dit
on l'a été beaucoup moins alors est-ce
que les toutes les toutes les réformes
qui se sont succédé et vous en avez vous
avez collaboré un certain nombre d'entre
elles d'ailleurs en tant que conseiller
est-ce que c'était lié à ça c'est que ce
soit moins généreux parce qu'au fond ce
chômage
on n'arrive pas à l'endiguer dans un
pays comme le nôtre et que donc on peut
pas continuer éternellement à payer puis
là il ya locaux vides qui fait que tout
à coup on a mis totalement l' économie à
l'arrêt on s'est mis à indemniser un
nombre de gens absolument
invraisemblable qu'on n'aurait jamais
imaginé devoir indemniser les
commerçants et donc forcément là est ce
que le gouvernement n'est pas coincée au
fond ils continuent de vouloir être
moins généreux qu'il ne l'était et en
même temps il ne l'a jamais été autant
alors sur la question du plus ou moins
généreux d'abord ya qu un certain nombre
d'indicateurs objectifs qui viennent
étayer ce constat la durée par exemple
d'indemnisation on est le deuxième pays
d'europe pour la durée d'indemnisation
derrière la belgique le plafond
d'indemnisation on est le premier pays
d'europe et de très très loin pour le
plafond d'indemnisation et même après 30
% dégressivité pour les plus hauts
revenus
et bien après ce palier 30% on restera
le plus romier près europe en terme de
plafonds d'indemnisation
et puis sur la durée d'ouverture
d'éligibilité c'est à dire le 4 mois
aujourd'hui qui pourrait passer à six
mois si un certain nombre de critères
sont réunis
eh bien on est le troisième pays
d'europe où cette durée est la plus
favorable donc ça c'est des éléments
factuels après sur la question vous avez
soulevés sur le fait de savoir s'il ya
certaine période on était plus ou moins
généreux je dirais que il faut poser la
question aux différents acteurs
il ya eu dans l'histoire de l'assurance
chômage qui a été créé en 1958
la plupart du temps des conventions qui
a été négocié entre les partenaires
sociaux
c'est les partenaires sociaux qui tous
les trois ans généralement négocier des
conventions d'assurance chômage et qui
permettait au vu de la conjoncture au vu
d'un certain nombre de paramètres
d'adapter dans un sens ou dans un autre
les paramètres d'indemnisation
ça s'est fait à plusieurs reprises à cet
effet en dernier lieu en 2017 et à trois
reprises dans l'histoire d'assurance
chômage
l'état a dû reprendre la main armée à
trois reprises seulement dans les années
80 dans les années 2000 hélas en dernier
lieu lors de cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage avec le décret de
juillet 2019
mais déjà je voudrais m'inscrire en faux
sur quelque chose qui a dit tout à
l'heure madame est doux quand elle a dit
que la négociation était rigoureusement
impossible pour les partenaires sociaux
les partenaires sociaux sont rentrés
dans la négociation il ya eu un document
de cadrage qui leur a été envoyé en
vertu des règles du jeu qui avait été
mis sur la table dans la loi de 2018 et
qui avait été discuté avec eux et ce
document de cadrage
il a été également discuter avec eux en
amont ce document de cadrage
il avait deux types de d'éléments qu'il
composait il avait des éléments de fond
sur ce qui devait aux yeux du
gouvernement être regardée dans la
négociation pour faire évoluer les
règles et il y avait notamment la
question de favoriser l'embauché sur des
emplois de qualité et des emplois
durables et puis il y avait des éléments
de nature financière
on était il faut le souligner avant
l'entrée dans la crise sanitaire
on était à un niveau d'endettement de
l'unedic qui était de l'ordre d'une
année de recettes
1 le niveau d'endettement de l'unedic
qui s'était perpétuer au fil des ans qui
s'était accumulée effectivement avec des
niveaux déficit qui était de l'ordre de
3 à 4 milliards par an dans les
dernières années avaient atteint quelque
chose de l'ordre de 40 milliards à peu
près qui représentait une année de
recettes donc on était obligé également
de tenir compte de ça de tenir compte de
la situation du marché du travail et de
tenir compte de cette situation
d'endettement de l'unedic la dette étant
il faut le rappeler garantis par l'état
c'est à dire par vous et moi par nous
tous donc c'est un sujet à la fois qui
concernait les partenaires sociaux et se
sont saisis de la question ils ont
négocié ils n'ont pas refusé de négocier
en dix ans la barre et rod nous n'y
arriverons jamais ils ont saisi la
perche que leur tendait le gouvernement
il ya eu plusieurs réunions de
négociation et j'ai la faiblesse de
penser que ils ont été un moment donné
même très proche de la possibilité de
signer un accord donc je m'inscris
totalement en faux sur cet arc
man qui consisterait à dire que la barre
était trop et c'est est rigoureusement
impossible
ils n'y sont pas arrivés soit et donc il
ya eu un décret après qui a tiré les
conséquences de cette impossibilité d'y
arriver qui encore une fois n'était pas
le premier du genre y en avait eu deux
autres dans l'histoire de de l'assurance
chômage qui l'avait précédé et les
règles ont été mis en place
alors voilà le contexte un le contexte
alors il ya une nouveauté que je veux
souligner dans le décret qui vient de
paraître qui n'existait pas dans le
décret précédent et qui est très
intéressante par rapport à cette
question justement de la conjoncture
le conseil d'analysé économique avec
formulé une proposition il ya quelques
temps qui était de dire essayons de
faire en sorte que dans l'adaptation des
règles de l'assurance chômage on est une
logique un petit peu contracyclique
c'est à dire qu'on puisse détendre un
petit peu les règles lorsque le marché
du travail va mieux et les resserrer
lorsqu'il va un peu moins bien et le
gouvernement a saisi cette proposition
et l'a intégrée dans le décret qui vient
de sortir puisque on va avoir en réalité
plusieurs moments qui vont jalonner
l'entrée en vigueur des nouvelles règles
d'assurance chômage
on va avoir au 1er juillet le nouveau
calcul du salaire journalier de
référence qui est l'outil qui va
permettre effectivement d'inciter à ce
que les embauches se fasse plutôt sur
des emplois de qualité et de plus longue
durée
et puis si un certain nombre
d'indicateurs de retour à meilleure
fortune sont réunis et qu'ils sont la
baisse du nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
en catégorie a et le nombre d'embauchés
sur des contrats de plus d'un mois
et bien si ces indicateurs sont réunis
et bien au bout d'un certain temps un
certain nombre d'autres paramètres
d'indemnisation du chômage entrera en
vigueur tels que le rehaussement de
quatre mois à six mois de la durée
nécessaire de la durée de travail
nécessaire pour bénéficier d'une
indemnisation et le
décalage au sixième mois et non plus au
huitième mois du mécanisme de
dégressivité qui s'applique aux plus
hauts revenus
voilà donc ça c'est quelque chose
d'assez intéressant c'est la première
fois qu'on va utiliser cette mécanique
qui consiste à avoir une logique contra
cyclique dans l'application des règles
d'indemnisation du chômage
et puis je finirai sur un point madame
est doux tout à leur disait il faut pas
stigmatiser les demandeurs d'emploi et
penser que les demandeurs d'emploi sont
satisfaits d'être au chômage mais
personne de 10 à personne n'a jamais dit
ça et personne ne se situe en tout cas
pas moi je ne me situe pas sur un
registre je dirais qu'ils ne soient pas
objectifs et rationnels
je pense simplement que quand vous avez
les règles quelle qu'elle soit pour
quelqu'un deux acteurs quels qu'ils
soient
eh bien vous vous adapter à ces règles
et vous adapter la manière dont vous
vous organisez par rapport à ces règles
et dire ça c'est faire injure à personne
c'est simplement renvoyé à la manière
dont tous les acteurs
et quand je dis tous les acteurs c'est
pas que les demandeurs d'emploi
d'ailleurs c'est les entreprises aussi
parce que les entreprises quand elles
vont avoir recours à des cdd de courte
durée plutôt qu'à des cdi
c'est aussi parce qu'elles vont le faire
dans le cadre d'un écosystème global
avec des règles qu'elles connaissent et
avec lesquels elle compose un exemple
d'ailleurs un des doutes vous ne
contesterait pas c'est les sociétés de
production à la télévision par exemple
n'hésite pas effectivement à se servir
de ça pour employer des techniciens par
exemple plutôt un jour sur deux qu'un
sursaut ou de jour sur 3 on sait que ça
existe c'est possible oui mais
l'instrumentalisation là elle n'est pas
le fait des demandeurs d'emploi mais je
voudrais répondre la plus précisément
aux différents points qui ont été
abordés un premier point je dirais c'est
les éléments de langage qui sont très
habituel pour justifier les réformes
le premier c'est de dire que le système
français est très généreux ou même que
la france est impossible à réformer
donc le système
ans ait été l'un des plus généreux
d'europe y compris dans les années 70
c'était pas vrai on avait aussi une très
grande générosité des systèmes
d'indemnisation du chômage en allemagne
d'ailleurs au début des années 2000
avant les réformes parce que le système
allemand était plus généreux entre
guillemets que le système français est
d'ailleurs la générosité de des systèmes
d'assurance chômage ça devrait plutôt
être quelque chose de rechercher puisque
finalement si on prend l'exemple
français mais dans beaucoup de pays
d'europe les moments le système
d'assurance chômage était le plus
généreux c'était aussi les moments où le
chemin j'étais le plus bas c'est à dire
que la générosité du système n'a jamais
empêché les demandeurs d'emploi de
retrouver un emploi dès lors qu'il y
avait de l'emploi et les difficultés
qu'ont aujourd'hui les demandeurs
d'emploi à retrouver un emploi s ils
sont pas causés par la générosité du
système le fait de rendre le système
généreux n'accélérera pas du tout le
retour à l'emploi puisque le retour à
l'emploi
il dépend d'autres choses il dépend des
créations d'emplois donc ça c'est le le
premier élément de langage qu'on
retrouve toujours chez les réformateurs
et qui historiquement est faux deuxième
élément de langage c'est le déficit de
l'assurance chômage
alors effectivement en fil de l'histoire
quand on a durci les droits c'est plutôt
parce que les partenaires sociaux
n'arrivaient pas à s'entendre dans des
moments d'augmentation du chômage pour
augmenter les cotisations et parce que
l'état ne venait pas toujours secours du
système
par contre là où ça a été très différent
dans la réforme qui a été décidée à
l'automne 2009
c'est que fait sans précédent l'état a
demandé aux partenaires sociaux de
renégocier une convention d'assurance
chômage alors même qu'ils venaient de
s'entendre sur une précédente convention
monde un an avant une convention qui
déjà décidé de faire des économies
donc c'était complètement
incompréhensible pour tout le monde que
à le gouvernement demande aux
partenaires sociaux de faire encore plus
d'économies
alors même que les simulations du medic
bien sûr personne n'avait prévu la crise
sanitaire et le financement du chômage
partiel
alors même que les simulations de
l'unedic prévoyait un retour à
l'équilibré pour 2021 bon donc là on a
un calendrier gouvernemental qui était
incompréhensible
et puis l'argument du gouvernement
c'était le déficit de l'unedic
mais finalement le déficit de l'unedic
le gouvernement l'a complètement oublié
quand il s'est agi de du quoi qu'il en
coûte et des dépenses massives de
chômage partiel plus de 35 milliards en
2020 et donc là on a complètement oublié
le problème du déficit de l'unedic
on était dans quoi qu'il en coûte et
d'ailleurs la france a davantage dépensé
en chômage partiel que pour l'hôpital et
pour les mesures sanitaires
donc ça donne quand même un ordre d'idée
du fait que tout d'un coup tout devient
possible du côté de la dette
donc ça c'était le premier point de la
réponse
et puis je dirais un autre point que
vous avez évoqué c'est le fait qu'on
allait rendre l'assurance chômage
contra cycliques c'est-à-dire plus
performantes en temps de crise
en fait elle l'a toujours été c'est à
dire que pendant la crise de 2008 il ya
eu des mesures qui ont été prises déjà
il ya les stabilisateurs automatiques
qui font que les défenses d'assurance
chômage augmente automatiquement mais on
décide toujours en france dans les
autres pays d'europe aux états unis
pendant la récession de 2008 d'augmenter
la générosité l'assurance chômage en
terme de durée par exemple
et de fait pendant la crise sanitaire on
n'a pas augmenté la générosité
d'ailleurs c'était un peu sans précédent
mais on a retardé une réforme dont on
savait qu'elle qu'elle ne serait
vraiment très dur pour les demandeurs
d'emploi donc ces contrats cycle par
contre ce que veut faire le gouvernement
sait mettre en place une forme
d'automaticité 1 ça c'est le rêve
technocratique néolibérale du pilotage
est automatique
on introduit des paramètres dans la
machine et donc au lieu de laisser les
partenaires sociaux négocier sanaa
une situation on met des paramètres pour
que les réformes passent automatiquement
mais en général il s'agit de réformes
extrêmement dure et là en l'occurrence
paul annonce que l'on met des paramètres
dans la machine mais finalement la
réforme allait déjà décidé et on
pour l'instant on voit pas vraiment la
reprise se dessine donc il devait mois
mais dont je suis obligé de vous nous
interromprons fait une pause et on
reprend salle juste après d'accord la
crise du côté de 19 à semble-t-il mis en
lumière lippert mondialisation et les
contraintes qui vont avec
démondialiser pas sur un coup de
baguette magique ça coûte cher de
relocaliser il faut aussi changer ce
pourquoi les entreprises sont partis il
ya de grandes façon de le voir et qui
implique des stratégies qui sont
complètement différentes
vous pouvez essayer de refaire venir de
la vieille industrie qui a disparu ou
des secteurs qui ont disparu mais s'ils
ont disparu il ya une vue il ya une
bonne raison
l'autre façon de voir c'est de savoir
quels sont les nouveaux secteurs
auxquels sont les secteurs l'avenir
qu'on peut arriver à conserver chez nous
si un jour on veut re localiser et bien
il faut déjà empêché les cerveaux de
partir ou en tous cas lors donner des
moyens pour qu'ils aient envie de rester
[Musique]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une robe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage avec ain et doubs
qui fait partie des économistes atterrés
et avec franck morel qui est avocat
expert en droit du travail et qui était
conseiller social d'edouard philippe à
matignon quand justement cette réforme a
été décidé je veux je vais vous redonner
la parole à des doux mais j'aimerais
qu'on rentre dans le détail de cette
réforme elle même puisque vous même avez
dit que ça allait toucher 40 % des gens
qui sont allés sur ans chômage que
l'unedic a dit que ça allait toucher
directement tous ceux qui avaient été au
chômage partiel en arrêt maladie ou en
congé de maternité et que ça allait se
traduire par une baisse des allocations
de plusieurs centaines d'euros par mois
alors qu'en est il exactement et je vous
donne la parole d'abord avoué des doux
alors disons que je n'ai pas à me
plaindre voilà l'unedic à documenter
cette réforme un donc en en montrant
l'importance mais je dirais c'est un
élément important c'est le calcul du de
ce qu'on appelle le salaire journalier
de référence c'est-à-dire que d'habitude
les demandeurs d'emploi sont indemnisés
à proportion de leur salaire de leur
salaire journalier et que la
l'innovation qui a été introduite dans
la réforme c'est que pour tous les
demandeurs d'emploi qui ont des
discontinuités dans l'emploi
c'est-à-dire qui alterne des périodes
d'emploi et de chômeurs des de chômage
donc les demandeurs d'emploi les plus
précaires et bien en fait on va faire
une moyenne entre les les revenus qu'ils
ont perçues et puis les périodes où ils
n'ont pas travaillé et donc au lieu de
de garder la référence à leur salaire
journalier
c'est à dire à ce qui touche aux
antilles sont en emploi
eh bien on va faire une moyenne de ce
qu'ils touchent par mois et donc ça va
effectivement considérablement dégradé
leurs revenus donc ce qu'on peut retenir
c'est que c'est effectivement les plus
précaires qui vont être les plus
pénalisés et que dans ces précaires et
bien on a aussi beaucoup de personnes
qui ont je dirais essuyé les plâtres de
la crise sanitaire c'est à dire qu'ils
se sont trouvés au chômage pendant la
crise sanitaire notamment on va lancer
pendant premier confinement les premiers
à perdre leur emploi
ça a été toutes celles et ceux qui
avaient des cdd des contrats courent
beaucoup sans rester durablement au
chômage ont pu éventuellement reprendre
un petit emploi pendant l'été quand ça
allait mieux et et risquer de le perdre
de nouveau un peu certains secteurs sont
particulièrement concernés et donc voilà
après la crise sanitaire eh bien on va
les punir je dirais c'est la double
peine ils ont une précarité qui a été
très augmentée par la crise sanitaire et
ils vont avoir la sanction de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui va compter
toutes ces périodes non travaillées et
ces périodes non travaillées qui vont en
fait réduire leurs droits à
indemnisation
et pour prolonger un petit peu donc il
ya une partie de ces demandeurs d'emploi
qui vont perdre même tout droit à
l'assurance chômage et certains vont
basculer vers les minima sociaux mais
pas tous hein il faut se rappeler qu'il
ya une très grosse différence entre
l'assurance chômage qui est un droit
personnel et qui dépendent d'eux d'une
trajectoire passé en emploi avec les
minima sociaux qu'ils sont des minima
liés aux ressources du ménage est donc
en fait un certain nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi au moment où ils perdent leurs
droits à l'assurance chômage perdre
aussi tout droit à toute forme
d'indemnisation parce que ces personnes
sont dans un foyer où les ressources
sont supérieures au seuil d'éligibilité
alors en france on n'a pas beaucoup de
données sexuée bo vraiment dorée des
réformes par mon allemagne où on a eu
des réformes très très dur de
l'assurance chômage qui ont fait
basculer comme ça des demandeurs
d'emploi de l'assurance chômage et un
minima sociaux mais on s'est aperçu que
la hausse était le plus dur c'était pour
les femmes en couple parce que les
femmes en couple en allemagne comme en
france
elles gagnent souvent moins que leurs
conjoints et donc elles sont les
premières à à perdre non seulement les
droits à l'assurance chômage
mais en fait un avoir aucun droit
alternatif puisque lorsqu'elles sont en
couple avec un conjoint qui gagne sa vie
elles perdent toute forme de droits
personnels à un revenu ça peut arriver
aussi pour des hommes en couple mais ça
va concerner principalement des femmes
et ça c'est complètement hors des radars
des débats effectivement on voit que les
défenseurs dans la note du cae défendent
l'idée que finalement pour ces plus
précaires on pourrait très bien passer
vers les minima sociaux ils réclament
d'ailleurs une fusion des minima sociaux
dans un revenu universel d'activité mais
voilà c'est pas du tout la même chose
dans l'assurance chômage et de l'una
sociaux et au passage devant certain
nombre de personnes vont se retrouver
complètement privés de droits sans
compter que des minima sociaux sont
quand même à un niveau faible
très peu revalorisés en france en
dessous des seuils de pauvreté
et donc voilà ça compense pas du tout
une nation chez morel ce que des années
d'où sur le sol sa verve journalier de
référence c'était un peu près ce qu'on a
reproché aussi à la réforme des
retraites
c'est à dire de passer d je ne sais plus
quand on calculait la retraite sur les
meilleures années ou au contraire quand
on fait la moyenne de l'ensemble des
années évidemment que forcément ça
allait baisser ce qu'elle semble dire si
ça va être exactement la même chose pour
la calcul des indemnités chômage
non c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
par rapport à la comparaison que vous
faites avec les retraites c'est pas tout
à fait la même chose parce que
précisément l'exemple que je prenais
tout à l'heure en comparant quelqu'un
qui est en cdi à temps partiel ou
quelqu'un qui est en cdd entrecoupées de
périodes de chômage et bien dans ces cas
là
première personne est pénalisée par
rapport à la seconde pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui on ne va prendre en compte
que les périodes travaillées et pas
l'ensemble de la période de référence
si vous prenez l'ensemble de la période
de référence là vous rétablissez une
égalité entre ces deux types de
situation ça c'est un point extrêmement
important ensuite je voudrais répondre
sur un autre aspect qui me paraît
essentielle parce que j'ai l'impression
en écoutant madame est doux que
l'assurance-chômage est isolé dans un
îlot où rien n'existerait à côté et
notamment madame edou parlais tout à
l'heure de l'activité partielle pour
regretter le fait que l'unedic et
participer au financement de l'activité
partielle déjà premièrement l'activité
partielle n'est pas financé par l'unedic
depuis la crise
elle est financé par l'unedic depuis de
nombreuses années selon une clef deux
tiers/un tiers entre l'état être entre
les partenaires sociaux la crise
sanitaire n'a rien changé à cela
alors après dois-je comprendre de ce que
vous avez dit qu'il aurait fallu qu'on
ne finance pas l'activité partielle que
ni l'état ni l'unedic ne finance
l'activité partielle telles qu elles
l'ont fait le choix qui a été fait il
est éminemment souhaitable
il fallait le faire de financer
massivement l'activité partielle parce
que si on ne l'avait pas fait là pour le
coup le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
aurait explosé beaucoup plus que ça
n'est le cas aujourd'hui
et d'ailleurs on a certes un exemple
dans le monde où nous ne disposons pas
de mécanisme d'activité partielle tels
que ce que nous avons et aux états unis
par exemple et où le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi a explosé et donc on
a bien fait on a eu grandement raison de
mettre en place un système d'activité
partielle très généreux le plus généreux
d'europe et on a eu bien raison de le
faire ça à sauver massivement des
emplois est la clé de financement unedic
état de deux tiers/un tiers a été
appliquée comme elle était appliquée
auparavant et je ne pense pas que les
partenaires sociaux ont été en désaccord
par rapport à ce financement
ça c'est un point extrêmement important
alors ensuite il ya un autre point la
politique de d'indemnisation du chômage
les règles l'adaptation des règles
d'indemnisation du chômage n'est pas une
politique qui est isolé mais qui prend
place dans une ensemble beaucoup plus
vaste de politique de l'emploi et
notamment la formation des demandeurs
d'emploi
il est extrêmement important de déployer
des moyens assez considérable et c'est
ce qui a pu être fait avec le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
pour justement permettre aux demandeurs
d'emploi d'être formés notamment aux
nouveaux métiers aux nouveaux besoins
pour accéder plus facilement à l'emploi
autre élément une partie des économies
qui étaient programmés dans la réforme
de l'indemnisation du chômage ont été
dédiés à l'amélioration de
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
et il faut dire une chose les économies
on les a pas vus pour l'instant parce
que la crise sanitaire est passée par là
mais en revanche les moyens
supplémentaires en direction de pôle
emploi
eux ils ont été déployés il ya eu un
certain nombre de recrutements qui
aurait été fait pour accompagner plus
efficacement les demandeurs d'emploi et
ça c'est un tout si vous voulez il ya
les règles d'indemnisation
il ya les règles d'accompagnement il ya
l'écosystème plus générale avec aussi la
possibilité d'adapter l'activité
l'activité partielle les accords de
performance collective la pld tous ces
mécanismes doivent contribuer à une
reprise efficace
je vais vous donner un exemple je lisais
il ya quelques temps un chiffre que
donner les professionnels de
l'hôtellerie restauration qui disait on
risque lorsque on va potentiellement
ouvrir au mois de mai on risque d'avoir
un déficit de l'ordre de cent mille
personnes qui ne seront pas au rendez
vous cent mille personnes dont on aura
besoin pour pouvoir ré ouvrir qui ne
seront pas au rendez vous ça c'est
évidemment inacceptable
il faut qu'on mette tout en oeuvre pour
accompagner les acteurs et leur
permettre d'ouvrir deux je dirais de
déployer leurs activités dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et on a
eu une première expérience de cela on a
eu une première expérience entre les
deux confinement parce que qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé on a eu une augmentation
massive en mars et en avril comme jamais
vue auparavant du nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi on a pris 1 million en deux
mois de demandeurs d'emploi en deux mois
on a gommé toute la baisse du nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi qu'on avait connue
depuis le début du quinquennat
et puis dans les mois qui ont suivi
après mars avril on avait une décrue et
on a eu à un moment donné avant
malheureusement qu'on soit obligé droit
confie d une seconde fois
on a eu une amorce de reprise et une
amorce de reprise qui était assez
vigoureuse
et donc le pari qui est derrière la
réforme et le pari qui est fait c'est
que lorsqu'on va sortir la tête de l'eau
de cette crise sanitaire
eh bien il va falloir faire en sorte
d'accompagner le plus vigoureusement
possible le plus efficacement possible
une reprise rapide et pour faire ça eh
bien il va falloir mobiliser tous les
instruments de la politique de l'emploi
c'est pour ça que les primes à
l'embauché d'apprentis ont été
prolongées et ont permis d'éviter que
l'apprentissage plonge pendant la
période de crise sanitaire
c'est pour ça que les règles
d'indemnisation du chômage sont adaptés
avec le svr qui est la pièce maîtresse
du dispositif dès le 1er juillet mais
les autres règles ensuite si retour à
meilleure fortune
et c'est pour ça que d'autres
instruments de la politique de l'emploi
tels que la formation des demandeurs
d'emploi sont mobilisés pour l être
peut-être plus je pense pour ma part
qu'on pourrait peut-être aller encore
plus loin sur cette question de
formation des demandeurs d'emploi il ya
un certain nombre d'outils très
intéressant très pertinent qui existent
qu'on pourrait mobiliser plus largement
le sjr je le rappelle c'est le salaire
journalier de référence
oui mais bon alors bon sur le chômage
partiel je suis tout à fait d'accord que
ça a permis de contenir l'effondrement
de l'emploi il a été tout à fait
essentiel est là dessus tout le monde
est d'accord la seule chose que je
voulais dire c'est que tout d'un coup on
a oublié le déficit de l'unedic qui
était complètement paralysant pour
comment dire ça mais je suis pas un bon
disque dur que de réparer ses récits
pour parler s'il vous plaît tant aux non
disait auparavant qu'il fallait faire
des coupes dans l'assurance chômage
parce que déficit était intenable et
puis tout d'un coup on décide que
finalement on va oublier le déficit et
qu'on va soutenir l'emploi coûte que
coûte
c'est tout à fait normal qu'on l'ait
fait mais voilà on doit aussi pouvoir se
dire que le déficit de l'unedic doit
être acceptable pour soutenir les
demandeurs d'emploi dans une période
extrêmement difficile
concernant maintenant les politiques de
l'emploi je ne veux pas vous apprendre
que elles n'agissent comarch de l'emploi
qu'en france elles sont extrêmement
faibles si on compare par rapport aux
pays du nord de l'europe
au point où les politiques de l'emploi
je dirais sont beaucoup plus intensive
joue le rôle de l'état joue le rôle ou à
jouer le rôle d'employeur en dernier
ressort c'est à dire de garantir des
mesures pour des demandeurs d'emploi de
longue durée
là en france figurait depuis les années
80 on a des politiques de l'emploi qui
aménage des marges de l'emploi assez
précaire mais qui n'ont jamais réussi ni
à lutter contre le chômage ni à amorcer
une quelconque reprise
on est vraiment et on est toujours dans
un grand manque d'ambition il ya eu par
exemple les mesures un joli une solution
mais qui en fait n'ont fait que recycler
des mesures qui existaient déjà quitté à
les intensifier un tout petit peu quand
on peut au plan d'investissement dans
les compétences bas on sait très bien
ainsi que voilà il est même si
s'intensifie petit à petit il est quand
même très insuffisants pour garantir non
seulement la qualification de l'ensemble
des demandeurs d'emploi parce qu'on a
aussi beaucoup de formations courtes
mais surtout ce qui manque à la sortie
la formation ça occupe les demandeurs
d'emploi mais ce qui manque à la sortie
c'est des créations d'emplois et pour
l'instant c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui manque
et pourtant on a des besoins on a des
besoins majeurs et mais on manque d'une
politique de relance d'une politique de
relance qui assurerait une transition
écologique déjà parce que ça ça paraît
un défi tout à fait majeur
et puis une transition sociale on a
besoin de créer des emplois l'hôpital on
a besoin de créer des emplois dans les
services publics dans dans les écoles
enfin le voilà les écoles sont restées
ouvertes pourtant on a pas on n'a pas
les moyens de dédoubler les classes
peut-être qu'on a aussi des besoins de
deux locaux enfin les besoins ils sont
totalement massif dans les services
publics
ils sont massifs pour la transition
écologique mais on nous propose
vous ne proposez que finalement des
mesures de formation assez ponctuelle
qui vont peut-être effectivement faire
réduire le chômage jusqu'aux prochaines
élections mais qui ne permettent pas de
tracer une ligne vers le futur 1
dans le plan de relance qu'annonce le
gouvernement finalement on a quelques
mesures un petit peu verte là on voit
bien qu'elles sont quand même très très
décevante par rapport à des mesures qui
ont été mises en débat donc voilà on
s'est quand même pas très très ambitieux
et puis aujourd'hui on nous annonce que
il va falloir réduire les déficits et
donc on nous annonce de nouveau des
politiques d'austérité qui sont
complètement contraire à toute forme de
politique de relance ont donc je dirais
que on n'a pas aujourd'hui un chemin qui
nous permet d'envisager une reprise et
qui permettent aussi d'envisager une
trajectoire
voilà industriel écologique social pour
le pays pour se sortir de de la crise
non seulement la crise sanitaire
d'aujourd'hui mais une crise
environnementale qui est social qui est
plus généralement on avait quand même
les gilet jaune on avait les
manifestations quand un julien l'hôpital
était déjà dans la rue avant la crise
sanitaire les on atteint voilà il y
avait déjà une crise sociale avant la
crise sanitaire qu'on a tendance à
oublier aujourd'hui mais qui est encore
devant nous parce que les mesures
montrent a été prise on va on va pas
faire abeba ce soit ce soir sur le plan
de relance ou même sur le tournant est
ce que c'est la fin du néolibéralisme
est ce que la france est à contretemps
par rapport à l'amérique de joe biden ou
même à la grande bretagne
aujourd'hui je voudrais revenir à la
réforme de l'assurance chômage parce qu'
un certain nombre de gens et vous en
faites partie à des doux pense que là il
ya une remise en cause avec cette
réforme de la gouvernance paritaire de
l'unedic
or c'est un reproche qu'on avait fait
aussi à la réforme des retraites où on
voulait où on expliquait que le
l'état était en train de remettre la
main sur les retraites qui était géré
jusque là pas les syndicats etc etc
et éclat l'état voulait de nouveau on
sent qu'il est le meilleur gestionnaire
du monde voulait prendre les retraites
elle son compte
alors est ce que ce serait ça là aussi
et là il serait question de reprendre la
main sur l'assurance chômage
votre réponse franck morel non il s'agit
pas de reprendre la main sur l'assurance
chômage
la mécanique qui a été mise en place à
travers la réforme de 2018 est une
mécanique que je qualifierais de
tripartisme assumer ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que l'ensemble des acteurs
sont légitimes les partenaires sociaux
sont légitimes pour négocier et ils
l'ont fait à maintes reprises dans le
passé les règles d'indemnisation du
chômage et les pouvoirs publics sont
légitimes également au nom de l'intérêt
général pour porter un certain nombre de
demandes en leur direction et mettre en
place un certain nombre d'éléments de
cahier des charges
donc une fois qu'on a dit ça il faut
trouver la bonne méthode pour concilier
ces deux légitimités et les concilier au
mieux permettant de définir de la
manière la plus efficace possible les
règles d'indemnisation du chômage
et c'est comme ça qu'a été mis en place
le système du document de cadrage qui
permet aux pouvoirs publics
en amont de dire voilà quels sont les
éléments qui nous paraissent importants
sur le fond et en termes d'objectifs
financiers et ensuite aux partenaires
sociaux d'exercer leurs responsabilités
vous savez ce mécanisme de documents de
cadrage il s'inspire d'un autre
mécanisme qui existe depuis 2007 et qui
a été utilisé à de très nombreuses
reprises par les partenaires sociaux qui
a permis de faire adopter un certain
nombre de réformes essentielles
la rupture conventionnelle les nouvelles
règles de représentativité syndicale
les nouvelles règles sur l'organisation
des restructurations dans les
entreprises et cetera et cetera
c'est les règles dites de la loi larcher
sait les règles en vertu desquels le
gouvernement quand il envisage une
réforme
eh bien il envoie un document
d'orientation aux partenaires sociaux il
saisit les partenaires sociaux ceux-ci
négocié et ensuite à deux hypothèses
soit les partenaires sociaux arrivent à
un accord et le gouvernement tient
compte tout ne tient pas compte mais en
tout cas il ya cet accord qui est dans
le paysage est politiquement c'est un
point important
soit ils n'arrivent pas à un accord et
le gouvernement reprend la main c'est ce
qui s'est passé de la même manière avec
le document de cadrage en matière
d'assurance chômage
il ya eu un document qui a été envoyé il
ya eu une négociation cette négociation
s'est déroulée avec plusieurs réunions
importantes
elle a échoué n'a pas réussi à aboutir à
un accord et je le regrette
et quand je dis je le regrette je le
regrette sincèrement parce que je pense
que ça aurait été très positif pour
l'assurance chômage pour les partenaires
sociaux et pour l'ensemble des acteurs
qu'on puisse s'adosser à un accord ça
n'a pas été le cas
c'est dommage mais du coup le
gouvernement a pris ses responsabilités
et a fixé les règles par décret la
situation va se reproduire puisque ces
trois ans une convention d'assurance
chômage
ces trois ans donc la dernière était en
elle a été hélas je répondrai à ce que
disait années d'où tout à l'heure quand
elle disait qu'on n'a pas attendu la fin
on n'a pas attendu la fin elle a été
avancé d'un an d'un an
la fin de la précédente convention
d'assurance chômage pourquoi parce que
dans la loi de 2018 il y avait deux
dispositions qui correspondent à une
promesse qu'avait fait le président de
la république pendant la campagne
électorale qui est l ouverture de
l'assurance chômage au démissionnaire et
l'ouverture de l'assurance chômage aux
indépendants et il aurait été sans doute
un petit peu compliqué d'un côté de
poser ses règles dans la loi de 2018 et
un an après une année entière à prêt à
revenir sur l'ensemble des autres règles
il était plus simple plus pratique et
plus cohérents avec l'ensemble de la
politique de l'emploi de tout traiter en
même temps et donc c'est pour ça que ça
a été traité en 2019
mais le prochain rendez vous désormais
il sera en novembre 2000 22 novembre
c'est là que les règles qui sont issus
du décret qui est paru il ya quelques il
ya quelques jours vont cesser de
s'appliquer et que avant cette
expiration de novembre 2022 et bien on
connaîtra le même cycle d'envoi d'un
document de cadrage de négociations et
en fonction des résultats de ces
négociations soient d'application des
règles curan été négociés soit de
transposition par un décret alors entre
les deux il ya les élections
présidentielles donc peut-être que ça
sera elle-même sans doute et c'est très
bien comme ça ça sera un élément de
débat de la prochaine présidentielle est
en tout cas c'est ce qui est prévu pour
l'instant années d'où qu'est ce qui vous
fait dire
vous que tu vous y voyez vous dans cette
réforme une remise en cause de la
gouvernance paritaire
il ya une pincée clair quand vous parlez
de documents de cadrage de décret il ya
eu une reprise en main par l'état cette
reprise en main à la lieu mais je dirais
d'une certaine manière elle était déjà
annoncée dans lorsque emmanuel macron
était candidat à la présidentielle il
avait cette mesure qui est passé de
suppression des cotisations salariales
pour financer l'assurance chômage mesure
qui n'a pas du tout été présenté pour ce
qu'elle était qui était une mesure qui
avait un très lourd impact sur la
gouvernance de l'assurance chômage
elle a été présentée comme une mesure de
pouvoir d'achat mais finalement dès lors
que les salariés ne financent plus
l'assurance chômage est bien calé dans
légitimité pour la gérer ça devient un
peu plus compliqué donc effectivement on
s'est trouvé avec des partenaires
sociaux un peu affaibli et avec une
moindre légitimité pour négocier et
parallèlement à ça la loi de 2018 a acté
une reprise en main par l'état de la
gouvernance et effectivement on a
finalement des documents de cadrage qui
encadre la négociation qui les font
capote qui font capoter les négociations
ont d'ailleurs on peut le dire comme ça
puisque les objectifs de d'économie
était tellement important que finalement
sa ronde et les choses là c'est
impossible
alors dire que c'était parce que on
changeait des petites choses dans
l'assurance chômage c'est à dire que
effectivement dans les annonces de
campagne du candidat emmanuel macron il
y avait l'idée d'ouvrir l'assurance
chômage aux indépendants alors ça n'a
pas été le cas on ça n'est pas de
l'assurance chômage qui a été ouvert des
indépendants puisque ce qui a été ouvert
aux indépendances et un minimum social
amélioré en c'est à dire un peu plus que
le rsa c'est un montant forfaitaire et
d'ailleurs ça a été ouvert à très peu
d'indépendants puisque des conditions
d'accès sont très difficiles et puis par
ailleurs l'ouverture aux démissionnaires
il
déjà possible sous condition de toucher
l'assurance chômage quand on était
démissionnaire
eh bien ça appelle étendu ce droit aux
démissionnaires et donc là aussi ça a
été une mesure de très faible ampleur
donc il ya eu des effets d'annoncé
extrêmement important mais finalement en
termes de réformes
il ya eu très peu de choses que peu de
personnes vont bénéficier de ces
réformes
donc voilà l'essentiel dans la réforme
ça a été quelque chose de très important
c'est le changement dans la gouvernance
c'est-à-dire la suppression des
cotisations sociales donc un financement
qui ne se fait plus par les salariés se
fait par la csg qui dépend de l'état
et puis parallèlement sa une reprise en
main ou par l'état d'aider des règles du
cadrage qui qui qui encadre les
négociations alors il nous reste à peine
deux minutes je vous en donne une chacun
pour conclure très provisoirement bien
entendu sur ce dossier franck morel
pour conclure je dirais que tout est
devant nous maintenant avec
effectivement la nécessité d'accompagner
de la manière la plus efficace possible
à la reprise avec donc de mettre le
paquet sur la formation des demandeurs
d'emploi je pense effectivement que il
faudra se pencher sur la question de
l'accès à l'assurance chômage pour les
indépendants parce que manifestement les
critères ont été trop resserrée et
manifestement on l'a vu avec la crise
sanitaire avec le fonds de solidarité
il ya un vrai besoin de protection de la
part de la population de travailleurs
indépendants et il faut répondre à ce
besoin de protection donc ça veut dire
qu'il faudra remettre à plat à remettre
sur la table cette question de filet de
sécurité pour les indépendants et puis
je pense qu'en sortie de crise va se
poser la question alors même qu'on a dû
gérer je dirais la sous-activité et
qu'on l'a fait avec principalement
l'activité partielle j'espère qu'on aura
à gérer la suractivité et qu'on aura
accompagné de la manière la plus
efficace possible la reprise
qui se posera la formation ce qui
supposera d'avoir les outils adaptés en
termes de contrats de travail ce qui
supposera d'avoir l'accompagnement
adapté de leur centre de l'écosystème
des dons en étant aussi concise c'est le
double alors je dirais que effectivement
devant nous il ya deux défis très
importants mais à un niveau d'inégalité
qui a vraiment augmenté avec la crise
sanitaire et donc je dirais qu'il ya une
première priorité qui est immédiate qui
aurait dû d'ailleurs être une priorité
déjà l'année dernière ces deux de
soutenir davantage les plus précaires
donc na de suspendre cette réforme de
l'indemnisation du chômage parce qu'on
n'est pas encore du tout dans un moment
de reprise et d'un moment où les choses
s'améliorent pour les demandeurs
d'emploi et puis par ailleurs en quelque
chose de très important qui est de
revaloriser les minima sociaux et de les
étendre notamment de les étendre en
direction des jeunes mans puisque on a
vu que des jeunes précaires et des
jeunes étudiants se trouvaient à
demander l'aide alimentaire donc il y a
ces réformes qui sont importantes et
urgentes
et puis je dirais pour la reprise il est
très important non pas seulement
d'investir dans la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi mais aussi
d'investir dans les créations d'emploi
et dont les créations d'emplois dont la
société a besoin donc des emplois dans
les services publics dans la transition
écologique et puis dans le soutien aussi
aux secteurs qui doivent se reconvertir
certains qui sont en difficulté
aujourd'hui comme l'automobile
l'aéronautique enfin voilà donc là il ya
vraiment des défis majeurs et c'est
effectivement pas simplement en formant
les demandeurs d'emploi que on
mon résoudre à cette question de la
reprise de la transition écologique et
puis je dirais de l'économie de demain
je remercie tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vous remercie
pour la qualité des échanges et pour
leurs cartes et d'ailleurs c'est
toujours agréable
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]